hey everyone i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's what I eat in a
date you to review is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're gonna be covering
the highly requested Erica Castel now
before we get too far into things I want
to chat about what I've been learning
through my Skillshare membership so if
you haven't heard of Skillshare they're
an online learning community with a wide
range of amazing classes for real life
that you can fit into your busy routine
when you have the time I've been trying
to learn how to edit some my own vlogs
so I've been taking the video editing
class transforming footage into
evocative travel stories by Oliver Astor
logo I love the tips for how to capture
video while traveling choosing the best
music for the story and techniques or
color grading and transitions but here
on my channel skill share is giving away
two three months of their premium
membership to the first 500 people who
click the link in the description box to
help you explore your creativity and
after that it's just ten dollars a month
okay so now before we get into the meat
of this episode just my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for education and entertainment
purposes only and you should always
speak to your health care provider about
your unique case okay let's meet Erica
so Erica is a beautiful model youtuber
singer songwriter and the owner of a
music label called BIA entertainment in
LA the girl has 4 point 5 3 million
subscribers on YouTube so it's safe to
say that people are definitely watching
what she does while most of her videos
are mainly just lifestyle vlogs of her
traveling going to glamorous California
places and trying on outfits she does
sometimes talk about her fitness and
diet routines since she is a model so in
a recent video she takes us through a
Monday through Friday of her diet
calling this week a detox week whatever
the hell that means but without adieu
let's take a look at some of those meals
I made a mess so this is what it looks
like altogether
wait this is okay so Claire oh that was
fast but and this is a solid breakfast I
like the combination of slow-burning
carbs from the oats faster carbs from
the banana
little healthy fats in there from the
almond butter and protein from the
protein powder let's take a look at day
- I had Courtney stop on her way over
and give me another celery juice I am
gonna break my fast if you guys have
watched any of my other vlogs like this
I normally don't eat til noon but I've
had a lot of questions on that so I
don't starve myself like if I'm hungry
and it's 9:00 a.m. I just start my fast
at 9:00 and then only eat for like seven
to eight hours after 9:00
my body is like they're used to these
cycles because I've been doing it for so
long
but I've had a lot of questions like oh
why do you wait till noon like bah bah
bah that's just normally what I've done
working on getting ready and having my
first meeting and like actually feeling
hungry but if I feel hungry earlier I
just do my fasting at a different cycle
so all I'm having right now is celery
juice I did bring the Celsius because I
am so tired today I am starving after
that I'm gonna go ahead and finish this
celery juice yeah girl I am NOT
surprised that you're starving you just
drank half of a celery juice for
breakfast which is literally just
basically water oh dear God I hope there
is a more substantial lunch on the way
because I am getting a little scared and
really hungry
I will just say that for a lot of people
the early research has shown that Antron
fasting is not necessarily any more
successful at promoting long-term
sustained weight loss when compared with
continuous caloric restriction so if it
works for you and you know Erica feels
great doing some kind of time restricted
eating great but I just want to flag
that it's absolutely not for everyone
let's take a look day three Lauri told
you I ordered a side of akkad Oh Amy
will probably only eat one half these we
save the rest for later if I get hungry
and then obviously the egg white and
then I also picked me up in acai bowl
acai bowls can be dangerous because
there is a ton of sugar in them so I get
them from the places I can do an
unsweetened acai and then on top here we
just got some coconut some blueberries
some strawberries and some banana
honestly I probably will only like take
a few bites of this and save it
throughout the day if I'm getting hungry
I don't understand why I like only a few
bites are enough there's really nothing
wrong with a little bit of carbs to pair
with this
super keto style breakfast going on
personally I would find this so
unsatisfying to me I mean at least get
the girl some ketchup her hot sauce for
the eggs just plain old egg whites with
a little avocado and a few bites of acai
it's not let's take a look at day four
bar snacks goes for today I'm gonna
bring a almond butter pocket I won't eat
both of these and plus I got happen for
a snack then hours go by and I don't
have time for food I'll take one of
these most likely and then bring it
Celsius war drink distilled Niemann
because I am acid a fully again this
just is not enough food this is not
breakfast it's a snack and she says that
but she doesn't really have breakfast
that day so to me it is breakfast I
don't really know how many banana chips
she's going to eat but I would say
there's definitely room to have the
almond butter and the almonds or even
better like the almond butter on a piece
of toast or Apple or on a sweet potato
and the almonds and banana chips crushed
on top like that would be delicious so
comment below if you're gonna try that
combo this week cuz I probably am but
yeah as the first meal of the day not
enough let's take a look at day 5 okay
so both little church by it so we're
gonna use water this time breakfast
that's what it looks like protein powder
tell me about this - I mean it Wow like
the last few scoops I'm using film
camera 40 - that's really good for this
like glowing green spotter from cambrian
line - it has a ton of greens in here
and caffeine so this is really really
good
[Applause]
gonna be a weird day again with groups
I'm gonna be in the studio and in
meetings then we have like a big dinner
tonight so yeah this is my breakfast
guys
it is about 11 o'clock right now I have
a lot of energy for my workout so I'm
not even take associations for anything
with me and if I do need caffeine I'll
probably end up getting a unsweetened
green cheese okay so this is pretty fine
in the grand scheme of her week but
still a pretty light breakfast in my
opinion this would be a great
post-workout snack to get the
combination of carbs and protein but it
would need to be followed by an actual
meal especially considering how long
this girl goes between meals and her
intermittent fasting schedule I would
definitely like to see this beefed up I
mean maybe she wants to throw in like an
egg or some Greek yogurt or a piece of
toast something to get a little more
satisfying fuel in the tank now I also
want to speak to this Celsius drink that
Erica seems to have every single day
let's take a look at what she has to say
about it different cycle so right now
celery juice I did bring the Celsius
because I am so tired today
so this Celsius is clearly what's giving
Erica her energy in the absence of
adequate calories a straight-up
stimulant drink now this makes a lot of
sense because I would probably just
sleep all day if I intrument fasted and
then broke my fast with something as
light as celery juice but basically
these are sugar free energy drinks that
claim they will boost your metabolism
and increase your ability to burn fat
and calories so each drink has 10
calories a few nutrients like biotin and
chromium which apparently curbs hunger
according to them but mainly it's based
on their proprietary blend of caffeine
green tea extract taurine guarana
extract which is just more caffeine glue
car on a lactone and ginger which
apparently causes thermogenesis oh my
god no okay let's get something straight
about caffeine and weight loss while
their research suggests that yes maybe
caffeine may slightly increase metabolic
rate and mobilize fat cells we know that
this isn't by that much like we're
talking between
three an 11% increase in your resting
metabolic rate and that over time your
body gets used to the effect and it
therefore makes no difference long-term
to your weight
likewise with green tea extract one
large 12-month study found no difference
between women taking a huge dose of
green tea extract and those taking a
placebo in terms of overall weight and
fat loss on the flipside high doses of
energy drinks have been shown to
increase blood pressure and cardiac
output so even though they are calorie
free and sugar free it doesn't mean
they're benign I would way rather see a
latte with some protein it from some
milk than a sugar free energy drink okay
let's move on because I'm starving
potatoes carrots potatoes potatoes
carrots onions mushrooms mushrooms
potatoes potatoes have to order for the
two but like this is the base of lunch
okay so love a good vegetable soup but
she does say that this is like the start
of her meal but that never really has
anything else so yeah that bowl probably
has like a hundred calories in it and
legit no protein or fat next up - right
now all they've had celery juice in
Celsius I ended up ordering a smoothie
from this place called
earth bar here at La some overnight OHS
and then this l-carnitine shot so when
I'm not home and I'm not cooking I
always order a smoothie just cuz it's
easy this is much overnight oats so this
is basically just a vegan overnight oh
thanks situation I don't think I think
that sheep family eats anything know
that smoothie has 500 calories in it
this has 270 calories in it and then
here is an Ultron teen shot it's
basically an energy shy lose your
metabolism I'm not taking it to boost my
metabolism today I'm taking it to boost
my energy and that's it we are obviously
very busy today and I have to do what I
have to do I know I'm so drained at the
moment I'm not really that hungry but I
know I need to eat time to eat so I got
eat greens one juice which has apple
cucumber romaine and kale in it
I got a little vitamin C shop and a
little bit of energy boost vitamin C and
then I got this chia seed pudding it has
almond milk almonds chia seeds raw honey
they all extract in cinnamon okay so
between the kind of lunch meal and I
guess the second snack thing together
there's a lot to unpack so Erica says
the smoothie has 500 calories and the
overnight oats have 270 calories which
if true would be a solid lunch maybe not
crazy balanced because I'm not sure
there's any veggies in there but at this
point I am just happy to see a meal that
gets past the 250 calorie mark she's
also taking some kind of l-carnitine
shot that can allegedly boost your
metabolism and boost your energy so yeah
let's talk about that so l-carnitine
is an amino acid that's naturally
involved in mitochondrial function and
energy production well it makes sense
that it may act as a weight-loss aid the
research does not seem to support it so
strongly once that he failed no
difference in those taking the
supplement other than the women who took
it experienced a lot of nausea and
diarrhea so I guess you lose weight
another study using it on 90-minute
cycling work has found no increase in
fat burning I was able to find one
analysis of larger bodied older adults
who found that using the supplement
resulted in 2.9 pounds more weight loss
than those who are using the placebo and
I found another study that found that
this kind of weight loss impact
decreased over time and therefore was
not sustained or even significant so I
think it's safe to say that Erica can do
without this one as for the vitamin C
shot I think this is unnecessary if
you're eating and drinking that many
fruits and veggies in juices and
smoothies it's really just expensive
toilet water in my books and since
vitamin C is water-soluble we can't
really Bank it for later so once you get
your fix which she easily did with the
smoothie or the juice you just kind of
pee out the rest I'm happy to see the
chia pudding at least we're getting some
of those added omega-3s and some fiber
here but alas I would love to see more
actual sit-down meals and not just
drinks and snacks also Erica I just want
to say that if you really want more
energy as it seems like you're
constantly reaching for supplements to
help with that I would just say eat more
food food equals calories which equals
energy so an extra meal or a couple
snacks would probably make a huge
difference in your stamina each day and
would eliminate the need for these
gimmicky supplements and energy drinks
let's take a look at day three your
hectic so I didn't get hungry again
until around like honestly 6 p.m. and I
had probably like 6 full servings of
water in this which I think has about 32
ounces so 30 60 I drink well over a
hundred ounces of water today which kept
me really full and when we switch over
location we did it have food accessible
when I was like well I know I have to go
dinner at 7:00 I'm just going to snack
so I honestly today was not the best
representation how I would normally eat
but I ended up eating my little almond
butter packet that I had with me in my
first and then hard from the studio got
some stuff from creation he picked me up
like little energy balls I have that
little protein balls ok so Erica admits
that this is not her best representation
for a meal and I would really hope that
that's true actually I'm just here
hoping this whole week isn't a stellar
representation but I digress
I mean it's becoming really apparent to
me that Erica does not seem to really
prioritize listening to her hunger and
instead tries to suppress it with a lot
of water and energy drinks in light of
her very busy lifestyle she said it
herself that the water keeps her really
full and maybe it does kind of stretch
your stomach out temporarily but this is
just a little trick or gimmick to pull
you away from having a balanced and
healthy relationship with your food and
body also please anyone who watches
Erica or is watching me watch Erica
know that if you're hungry even if you
are going to have dinner very shortly
it's ok to have a snack it's ok to honor
that hunger in fact having a snack might
just take the edge off enough that you
can make more mindful decisions
about what to eat rather than super
frantic hangry ones in the moment
remember what we talked about when we
talked about the hunger scale I like to
try to stick within a quarter to three
quarters of the way full whenever I can
just because that's the place that feels
best to me and also healthy make more
mindful decisions about what to eat but
it seems like Erica is really accustomed
to living on an empty tank so let's see
what else we've got in store big salad
like practically two and a half servings
of like enormous out I was eat yeah for
corny it's the same meal for like a
hundred a straight so I ordered a big
salad with chicken spinach and iceberg
lettuce oh it was a chopped salad
hard-boiled egg bell peppers cucumbers
carrots broccoli and then the dressing
was gluten-free vegan balsamic
vinaigrette so that's all that I've had
because I've been sitting in the hair
salon for five hours folks time to eat
again
so Erica describes this lunches being
huge which is good because she hasn't
really eaten that much today other than
the almonds and some banana chips so I
really hope that it actually is or was
substantial because I didn't see it but
having said that it's still not like
super balanced and I would still be
worried that it would be something that
would be really satisfying if you were
starving so it's great that we have
protein from the chicken and the eggs
and lots of veggies in here plus some
salad dressing which she described as
being gluten free vegan balsamic
vinaigrette hopefully there's some oil
in there too but it wouldn't have killed
her to throw in some quinoa or like a
piece of pita or something to beef this
up a little bit I don't know how huge
this chicken and egg portion is but I
would still call this a pretty light
diet eat meal in my books let's see
day five right we both got these little
brown rice salads which just has brown
rice I think it has green beans avocado
edamame some Tomatoes which I hate a
little bit of corn and then not pictured
is I had a grilled chicken breast and
breadhead grilled salmon and we're
drinking water hydrate Cheers
okay this seems like another small lunch
to eat which is apparently the theme
here but at least we're having a little
bit more about us going on you know
we've got some carbs in the brown rice
and we've got Pro
teen in the chicken plus a few veggies
in there as well I mean it's kind of
boring I would be bored eating like this
especially because breakfast this day
was just a smoothie but I mean it's a
better option than some of her other
days for sure so I guess I'll give her a
thumbs up on that let's move on to
dinner now and please Lord let there be
a feast we are ending the night with
some salad I don't really know what this
we will see cheese you don't I thought
you were vegan on I quit okay she's a
vegan tell us what you've made today
bread Caesar so it's made with vegenaise
which is a fake mayonnaise some Dijon
mustard some more sister sauce with
garlic Wow Wow and lemon there's no
anchovies in these right there isn't so
Skyler can't eat that oh wow I just
saved scholars like but in the important
part is I brought these cupcakes from
sprinkles which also I probably will
have a bite of but this isn't on the
detox round two of the vegetables into
the fresh pot fresh pot of the vegetable
soup made by gripper and herself the
Hopi and that's it for today okay so
love me a good Caesar vegan or otherwise
but in this meal we've really got no
protein going on just a little bit of
fat mainly vegetables and a bite of a
cupcake I mean I hope she ate the entire
bowl of salad and left nothing for
anyone else because girl that is what I
would do
let's see day two just simmering in
olive oil then over here this needs to
go low damn girl I'm just steaming some
Brussels sprouts I'll add some lemon in
there and then normally I don't eat
carbs at night this is like super rare
for me but I feel like I need some kind
of like substance to soak up whatever is
going on in my stomach if you want to
see what kind it is when I do have time
I make it fresh if not my mom found
these for me really good really easy you
just pop them in the microwave for a
couple of minutes give me just being a
freaking out way Wow might be ugh
this is super easy dinner again it
wouldn't really do the rice that
probably have something a little bit
more fun but I'm exhausted and I just
need my protein and my veggies and
something they cure my stomach and I'll
be back when it's done because his
chickens about the bird okay bye okay
guys I ended up seasoning my chicken
with this like sodium free chicken broth
packet this is what the final product
looks like I already ate some of the
chicken this I was starving but okay so
Erica says she normally doesn't eat
carbs at night but did tonight because
she mainly drank her calories that day
and felt like she needed more substance
and something was going on in her belly
so I can agree with that I mean this
definitely looks more balanced of course
but it definitely reminds me of some of
those super boring generic fitness model
diets that you read in magazines I mean
I guess that's because she's doing this
like detox week thing but still it's
just it's just not enough now this is so
low in calories in the context of her
whole day and I don't know about you but
I would personally go to bed starving
and unable to sleep after a super small
meal like this let's take a look at day
three there would be on a burger at
night then some red meat exciting always
something go to her in the morning so I
had that and instead of getting the bun
I always do this no matter what I got a
lettuce wrap for the bun so I had that a
side of veggies and water and then I did
eat some french fries as well not a lot
but like you know I'm not gonna stare at
french fries for three hours and Andy
like that's torture so how do those okay
so even though she talked about having
this big dinner out and that's why she
was eating like all day this is what I
would consider a really low calorie meal
even if we're accounting for the fries I
mean the vegan burger patty on a lettuce
wrap plus some veggies and like a few
fries maybe five three calories if I'm
being super generous this is hardly a
splurge meal that you need to save
calories for all day long she definitely
could have eaten more fries or the bun
or both without any damage done let's
look at day four I'm sorry you have no
any chicken vegetable situation so what
I'm gonna do is I just put two egg
whites one yolk and here gonna add some
seasoning this is a flour tortilla
cooked with olive oil for the healthy
fats I'm gonna add some veggies into
this and make it into like a breakfast
for dinner situation for like the fourth
day in a row not a typical like loving
what I'm eating but trying to be as
healthy and feeding my needs as much as
possible so that is dinner and this is
probably it for the day it's eight
o'clock and this is a lot of protein and
if there will be a lot of veggies in
here and olive oil has a lot of fat so I
should say four okay so I make myself a
graphs sometimes as well cuz they're
just like really easy convenient
inexpensive and fast but I'll need like
two of them for a snack probably so
admittedly this would leave me starving
at the end of the night especially again
in the context of her day also I have no
issues with cutting back on egg yolks if
you're watching your saturated fat
intake even though the evidence to date
suggests that a few egg yolks a day are
perfectly safe for the vast majority of
individuals but then to serve it in just
one tiny tortilla and a low carb coconut
flour one at that without any guacamole
or cheese or anything else that would
make this into a satisfying meal just
makes me really sad I mean it takes no
extra time to just fry up another
tortilla and scoop a little avocado on
top girl this just is not enough food
yes so we left off Friday for dinner we
went to this place called catch if you
live in LA and you've been to catch you
know the food there
we had a bunch of people at dinner so we
ordered a ton of appetizers but my main
thing that I order at catch all the time
is the spaghetti squash sounds super
lame and it's actually really really
good and then of course I snack on some
of the appetizers made of course
spaghetti squash fire and catch ten out
of ten recommend and then like eating
just like random bites of other stuff
okay so I have no clue what this meal
looked like because she didn't really
specify or show pictures but again she
seems to make a really big deal out of
restricting on days
she's going out for a big dinner only to
eat the lowest calorie item that she can
probably find now I love spaghetti
squash and I really hope that this one
came with like a nice creamy sauce or
some melty cheese or some kind of
protein on top and not just like a bowl
of naked slimy strands I also hope that
the appetizers that she was eating
included something with some protein and
some fat in there it wasn't just like
some la style jicama wraps or something
low calories now before we go any
further I want to of course take a
minute to talk about some of Erica's
supplements the vitamins that I take
daily are b12 vitamin C the sounds
disgusting but a fish liver cod oil you
do have to take that one with food
because it messes your stomach up if I'm
not taking the liver cotton oil I take
the fish oil just plain fish oil a lie
zine which is good for your skin hair
and like just overall immune system I
take a d3 and that's pretty much it yeah
okay so the fish oil is definitely a
great option as I don't think I saw any
fatty fish or other sources of omega-3s
in her diet likewise the b12 may help
with energy which she apparently lacks
for no other likely reason than she just
lacks getting enough calories in her day
the vitamin C seems like total overkill
considering the amount of smoothies and
juices that she drinks d3 is pretty much
essential for most people yes even in LA
assume that you practice safe skin
protection as for the l-lysine
this is an amino acid often used to
treat cold sores reduce anxiety
increased calcium absorption and improve
collagen production so if it's working
for her then I guess that's great
another thing guys are these de Bourgh
pills
I take these almost every single night
two of them what this is is just
magnesium
okay so I've talked about these pills
before when we discuss to fit with Kabri
which was a super problematic what I in
a day I might say but basically this
pill is just magnesium which is a known
laxative hence why it may help you feel
or look less bloated I mean you're just
losing more water volume in [ __ ] so yeah
I'm not surprised she's also suggesting
laxatives to help you
a flat stomach in the morning and that
brings me to the big questions the day
starting with in general is Erika's
dietary pattern and way of eating
balanced I would say a resounding no at
the start of this video erica described
her workout as a mile long jog than a
hit circuit and then another mile jog
that seems like a lot a woman of Erika
size and activity level should be eating
between 2000 and 2500 calories just to
maintain their weight and physique
some days Erika's intake was as low as
860 calories and on her best day we
barely hit 1430 calories which is still
not enough she's also usually lacking in
omega-3 fats and fiber so I guess I
understand the need for the magnesium
supplement to keep things moving along
there also doesn't seem to be a whole
lot of planning going on to these meal
choices and I get that Erica is crazy
busy that is so apparent here but we
really should still try to prioritize
eating so if you're going with green
juice maybe choose a salad with some fat
protein and complex carbs to go along
with it rather than like overnight oats
or chia pudding which probably also has
a lot more simple carbs added in next
are there any problematic claims or
assumptions made by this channel I would
say so I mean while Erica doesn't claim
to be a wellness influencer and I'm glad
that these videos aren't not like a
major part of her brand I still did hear
a few things in this video that I didn't
like so first she gets a lymphatic
massage which she insists helped you
flush toxins out tel with bloating and
she says helps make you feel smaller and
lighter now I went searching far and
wide and I wasn't able to find any
evidence that manual lymphatic drainage
techniques or you know lymphatic massage
is beneficial for healthy individuals I
was able to find research on its use for
athletes for post-traumatic edema or
swelling an injury rehab for like
fractures and sprains which does make a
a sense to me now it's possible that it
can help with general bloating a little
bit by like pushing gas through
digestive tract but I'm sure this is not
a cheap procedure especially to have it
done as regularly as Erica suggests that
she does I would say if you're dealing
with chronic bloating your money would
be much better spent seeing a GI doctor
and a dietician who specializes in
digestive health to really help you
determine the root cause of your
discomfort
Erica also uses a lot of toxic diet
culture language in her video and also I
see a lot of concern over her physique
and the need for a flat stomach
let's take a look weirdly I don't know
where I woke up feeling super flat
really like good and clean fans let me
remind you that it is completely healthy
and normal for your stomach to expand by
the end of the day after you've eaten
and drink no matter what you consume
you're not bad
or dirty for seeing some kind of
expansion after a meal and you're not
clean or good for waking up with ABS the
expansion and contraction of the gut is
a normal part of daily digestion can we
move along please more evidence of the
bloating obsession is her o2 epsom salts
hey or maybe it's not so great it's good
for your muscles good for blow but I
will say add some salt oh this is Epsom
salt by the way does dehydrate you which
is why if you look a little bit some are
the mornings so make sure if you're
doing these baths you're drinking a lot
of water
okay so epsom salts are just magnesium
sulfate which when taken orally is a
laxative so if you ate epsom salts sure
you would probably a lot and therefore
maybe temporarily look slimmer but
there's actually no good evidence that
magnesium or sulfates are absorbed
through the skin into your body so in
other words when you're using them in
the bath it's highly unlikely that
they're going to do a whole lot when it
comes to your bloating and finally on
the bloating were those deep bloat pills
which I already talked about which again
is also big knees iam and basically just
makes you poop I also just want to
mention the obvious and
now was that the whole eating clean
detox week is just such BS when asked
what her detox is to her she says he
really just depends on what works for
your body detox to me is more just
eating clean getting on a good schedule
making healthy choices making it like
more of a lifestyle have it I mean I
guess I agree with that even though this
is such a gross way to talk about food
but yeah detoxing is part of all of our
lifestyles because it's part of everyday
life it's something that our body does
naturally every single day without the
need to have an l-lysine shot or energy
drink with fat burners yes of course
eating a balanced healthy diet can help
this process along by providing fiber
and water to help a sweat P and toxins
out but there is nothing magical going
on here I mean this is just common sense
now can we take anything positive away
from Erica's diet well I know I think
we'll probably have some great ideas on
where to order my smoothies from if I
have a craving when I'm visiting LA this
month but no seriously I'm not sure that
the wellness content is really her bread
and butter anyway and I'm sure she's got
a lot more to teach us about the music
industry or fashion which is obviously
something I know nothing about my
recommendation is to maybe watch her
content for that rather than to take
nutrition advice about detoxes and how
to eat from Erica on that note again I
want to give a big shout out thank you
to Skillshare for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below about
who you want me to review next subscribe
to the channel and I will see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
you